our feeling was if we could find a way
to do it physically
the payoff would be well worth it movie
magic
often means using cgi to make the
impossible
possible like harry potter's epic
hogwarts battle
but there are other times where movie
magic actually means using practical
effects to make these moments real
not only on screen but in real life can
you guess what harry potter scenes and
other huge blockbuster movies use these
techniques instead
let's find out off we go
a spoonful of sugar makes the medicine
go down and
a bathtub of bubbles makes mary poppins
go down
literally the scene in mary poppins
returns that involves the never-ending
bathtub
probably could have been done using some
next level cgi techniques
but director rob marshall instead
decided to build their bathtub set
over an actual slide so when we see
emily blunt drop backwards into those
bubbles
she really just took a fun ride to
safety the most harm done was probably
the cast just getting a little wet
we all discovered the magic we're not
excusing the fact that ant marge
definitely deserved what she got in
harry potter and the prisoner of azkaban
but the way they made her inflation come
to life is
nothing short of awesome her actress pam
ferris not only wore
an inflatable suit but sat in hair and
makeup for hours while they placed
layers of prosthetics on her to make her
look 50 pounds heavier
the wildest part they attached rubber
bladders to her face
and air pumps to her clothing even her
floating was done using strings
instead of cgi and it's a lot easier to
say that than it is to do it
harry potter wasn't just good at making
cgi magic
but practical magic as well remember
this scene where harry sees the
self-washing dishes at the burrow
that was all an illusion done using
fishing string
another scene that used fishing string
the first shot of the great hall
the candles were being held up by string
as well until they
started falling on the actor's heads i
always shied away from
visual effects because i just felt that
i'd get bored with him
it's reassuring to know that when people
fall out of a plane during a movie
it isn't real but in this iron man 3
scene it
kind of was the creatives had
professional skydivers jump out of the
planes in order to make it look as real
as possible
and the ironman rescue part the stuntmen
were being held with harnesses while
iron man carried them to safety take a
look
[Music]
no matter what spider-man universe we're
watching peter and mj scenes will
always be topped here including when
toby mcguire managed to catch a tray of
lunch in one hand
while holding kirsten dunst with the
other it may have taken 156
takes without cgi but the super glue
covered tray eventually did
the trick this is what will be keeping
me alive for the foreseeable future
the arc reactor is basically iron man's
lifeline
so of course marvel had to make it look
as realistic as possible
so realistic that in this scene where
pepper has to replace the ark reactor
it was done with no cgi she literally
swapped out two live replicas
we're still trying to figure out if that
makes it more or less romantic
it's a weird fantastic thing there's
nothing like good old classic sleight of
hand magic
maybe that's why they decided to use it
during the joker's pencil trick in the
dark
knight the scene was shot in two takes
that were later edited together but
charles jarman still had to make sure he
was able to knock the pencil away before
landing on it
another real life effect in the dark
knight the epic car chase that involved
the flipping of a literal 18-wheeler
a stuntman drove the vehicle and
purposely flipped it in order to get the
final take in the film
there's even footage of the moments
behind the scenes
inception was full of epic shots that
had us questioning how they were even
filmed
including the fight scene where the
actors were using all four walls
director christopher nolan actually had
the crew built an entire
set that rotated for the actor the
reasoning for it
christopher just doesn't like using cgi
effects very much
the same concept was used in this
euphoria episode
everything is just spinning and you have
no sense of where the real world
is the dark knight didn't stop at the
pencil trick or car chase for practical
effects
the plane escape scene was also 100 real
they used a prop plane but still had the
stuntman drop down into it to capture
the moment where the cia plane is
destroyed
for the inside shots they used the
simulator hallway that was built for
inception
reduce reuse recycle right yes
the fire rises imagine being able to
make bread in literal seconds
like rey did here well what if we told
you
you can it just might not taste very
good
the recipe rey poured into that ball was
an actual real concoction that the
production team spent three months
perfecting
if you want to try it at home a quick
google search will give you plenty of
recipes
60 portions
like we mentioned earlier christopher
isn't a huge fan of cgi
so the inception scene where the paris
street explodes was shot using air
cannons instead
they set off each one individually and
used a special camera to capture it all
in slow motion
check out how cool the behind the scenes
footage is we did tests with people
sitting in front
and we showed them to leo and showed it
to ellen mad max is just an overall
wild film so we aren't surprised that
the guitar flamethrower we see here
was actually real not to mention it was
also a working guitar
the actor and musician iota who was
tasked with working it had to practice
for over a month on the moving platform
and had to be able to bungee jump
blindfolded there's also a flamethrower
used in a battle against max himself the
rock may be
the rock but he still had to get his
stuntman to jump in for the cgi-less
scene
his stunt double was attached to a rope
in order to jump off the bike swing
around the statue
and land on top of it the only
difference from the final product was
that the statue was smaller than it
looked on screen
the hobbit may have opted for the cgi
route for the orcs but in the original
lord of the rings
these costumes were achieved with
multiple hours of makeup and full body
prosthetics
that could not have been comfortable but
it turned out looking so epic on screen
lord of the rings had to find some ways
to make the hobbits look
smaller than the other actors and what
they settled on was force perception
basically they would have the human sit
closer to the camera and trick the eye
there's even an attraction at warner
brothers studios that you can visit to
see how it was actually
done elf also used the concept of force
perception to get will ferrell looking a
lot bigger than the elves in the
classroom
when we see him squeezing into his desk
here he was actually off in a corner
farther from the camera and on his own
platform
we love movie magic you know gone great
people were like oh my gosh this is
gonna be fantastic
arguably there wasn't much option for
cgi
back in the 70s but the way that they
got the exploding death star effect done
in a new hope
is still cool they recreated pieces of
the death star on set
and exploded them individually while
using the camera to make a size illusion
turns out mission impossible wasn't so
impossible after all
especially when it came to tom cruise
scaling a building for this scene
that's right the background is one
hundred percent
real and scary tom spent eight days in a
harness
one thousand seven hundred feet above
the ground filming this scene
don't worry beforehand they built a mock
building to make sure that everything
was 100
safe this scene in fast five it was
filmed exactly as it looks like
they had stuntmen in the cars pulling
mock bank volts behind them
while we're pretty sure they didn't
weigh as much as a real one
it must have been hard to navigate them
on the road
it 100 takes a lot of effort to
implement cgi effects
and get them perfected but we can't help
but love how much of a team effort
practical effects are in comparison
these movie moments just scream talent
from the director to the actors and
everyone in between
these effects just take these films to
another level what scene were you most
surprised to find out wasn't cgi